in the reference of landfills okay maybe
you don't to pay for it now but in 20
years and they're full you're still
going to end up paying for it so why
percent responsibility on to someone
else but don't you think the citizens
have a right to decide if they want to
go along with this I don't think that
citizens have the right to be wasteful
more than someone else my name is dawn I
am a professor of geology and a
professional climate scientist have
published in the field for many years my
name is Andrew I studied environmental
science policy and management when a
consultant that specializes in
sustainable tourism my name is Natalie
I'm a local government consultant and I
believe that anthropogenic climate
change is real my name is Michael I'm
the vice president of a nonprofit that
concerns itself with the threats to
Western civilization my name is dr.
James and strim I'm a physicist and
epidemiologist and I'm passionate about
scientific integrity
my name is Keith Hardeen I'm a
constitutional rights activist and I'm
concerned about the future of the next
generations may I please have my
activists to the left and my skeptics to
the right I believe global warming
should be our number-one concern
there's obviously a lot of issues that
our politicians deal with and as a
society we can care about but if our
earth is moving in a direction to our
species cannot survive then homelessness
then all the other issues that are out
there are going to be irrelevant because
we won't have a place to live I agree
that there are many issues that are
important at the local level and we're
not doing a great job with a lot of
things but things like extreme droughts
and stream heat waves and devastating
hurricanes and tornadoes are going to
make life harder on us no matter where
we come from no matter what our economic
background really if you want to look at
it as a issue of health
don't see why everyone wouldn't be
concerned and everyone wouldn't be
participating in ways to reduce the
impact of climate change or reverse
global warming no matter what the United
States does it's not gonna make an
impact on the worldwide greenhouse gas
emissions as long as China and other
parts of the world are increasing the
greenhouse emissions it puts the United
States at an economic disadvantage when
we try to transform our lives in the
other countries just simply ignore these
efforts the United States seems to be
the most held in responsible for the
global warming for for doing something
about it and that's what bothers me you
know we have a constitution and nobody
ever considers that Constitution the
importance of protecting the natural
rights of the individual and I think
global warming is a an infringement on
those rights and when I say global
warming at least the the agenda of the
political aspect of it I think it's time
to change how we live I really do which
we have seen how changing our habits
changing the the resources that we use
and what we pump into the air and how we
reversed that hole in the ozone we've
seen how it can change and we can change
it but we're going to have to make
changes well I don't believe that
climate change is our biggest problem
because I don't believe that man has
anything to do with that climate has
changed since before man existed on the
planet and will continue when man is
gone as a professional climate scientist
who's done this for 50 years I'm afraid
you're not correct the climate evidence
is very very clear and probably the
clearest evidence of all comes from
ancient records where we can actually
see what the planet was like before
humans were involved this is why climate
scientists 99% on almost every study of
climate scientists shows that wearing a
unanimous as scientific community ever
gets and that this evidence is real and
that it's happening and it's happening
on every scale from the ice caps to the
ocean every place we look we get the
same answer no I'm not a climate
scientist but I know a lot of them and
I've heard exactly the opposite argument
thousands of scientists just in the
United States signed a letter saying man
has little if any effect on climate
scientists that oh yes they actually
doing climate research and publishing in
it yes they are I don't believe I know
people who have been affected by
environmental regulations yes Wow
everybody agrees I miss him I have a
very good friend he is a trucker he was
able to be successful and maintain a
career for 40 years he was stopped in
that career because of claims that his
diesel truck was killing people through
the exhaust there was a program in Los
Angeles called a clean truck program
that basically put him out of work
because he couldn't afford to buy a new
truck so this is the kind of
environmental regulation that hurts real
people especially here in Southern
California I'll say also that many of
the people who owned homes they're not
allowed to water their lawns why because
of environmental regulation laws which
are suppressing again suppressing the
natural right to use water it seems like
an underlying issue with you guys as
money power choice and I grew up on a
farm where there was a lot of regulation
agriculture is very regulated and then
eventually there was this regulatory
thing that came in called the
Conservation Reserve Program where we
had to convert a part of our lands to
prairie at the time my dad was very
angry because we lost money from that
but that conservation area also created
a buffer between the farm fields and the
water to capture eroding soils that it
didn't go into the water and decrease
the water quality so I think there's
certain regulations that we need to look
at more long-term look at the bigger
picture and although we may be losing
money now we could be earning it greater
in the future we need to look at it a
bigger picture I really like your point
about the water and the regulation of
water because I can remember that from a
few years ago and the reason they put
that regulation in
because the snowpack wasn't there for
that year it's not like it was a random
year where the government just said
start charging people for water it's
because the effect of climate change one
of the aspects of it is that we are not
seeing consistent seasons and I
completely agree with a regulation that
you know limits the amount of water
about a precious resource that we have
to consumers the regulation a lot of us
didn't like when the cost of gas went up
here in California we all had had
catalytic converters but we've all
agreed in this group that were grateful
that the air is clean like it wasn't
when I was a kid and we don't want those
laws reversed because we'd be back to
the smog we had when I was a kid so
those regulations may not have been
great at the time they may not have made
people happy but we've all learned to
live with it and now we're grateful I'd
like to bring up my concern about China
again on some days the pollution levels
in China can be 10 to 50 times what they
are here in Southern California they
simply assign their citizens to wear gas
masks and then they take the jobs the
manufacturing jobs that used to be in
this area have now gone to China I might
be missing it but are you saying that
you would rather have that manufacturing
be in California and that we all wear
gas masks all the time because that
regulation that we have here that makes
it expensive to have manufacturing here
is what keeps us safe that is what makes
no sense it I think you're
misunderstanding me
you could bring manufacturing back just
like President Trump has done in various
parts of the United States by just
making the economics work so we can
still keep the clean air but we don't
need to keep beating down now some of
the regulations now are more severe than
they were 50 years ago and what you need
to do is talk to some of these
businessmen that are faced with this on
a day-to-day basis an eco-friendly
lifestyle is expensive
we all know we're paying twice as much
for gas as the rest of the country I pay
an enormous amount for energy in my
little tiny one-bedroom condo wind and
solar have been subsidized so I mean
we've already paid a fortune for it all
you know why not put some of these
regulations to a vote instead of the EPA
and all the rest of these administrative
arms placing these regulations on us
taking more and redistributing more of
our wealth or more of our money to pay
for something that we're not even going
to use or benefit from an eco-conscious
lifestyle does not need to be expensive
there are incentives that are built into
our policy that encourage people to live
a more eco conscious lifestyle because
you have control over that a lot of
things they don't have control over but
you have control over how much you're
buying at a grocery store and how much
you're deciding to throw away and
minimize that scale it back in all
regard in how far you're driving in the
water in the electricity and all the
different sectors that impact climate
change so you have the decision to make
of how much you're going to use and
there are direct cost savings with not
being so wasteful I'm also an example of
that I drive an electric car and it's
not that hard in Los Angeles to get it
charged and in the future it's going to
be much easier for more more people of
electric cars especially as the cost of
internal combustion engines keeps adding
up I spend a tremendous amount of time
recycling plastic recycling aluminum and
about every six months I go every cycle
yard myself and it pays off very
handsomely an aluminum is extremely
valuable there's a lot of small choices
and a lot of larger choices and you can
make those choices quite easily I mean
an entire yard is now all drought
resistant plants that's that is your
that is your choice but what you are
talking about is making choices for me
no you can choose to keep using water
but you're gonna pay for it you can
choose this lot of your green lawn no
one is coming around and saying you
cannot do that but you are going to pay
for it look at we can have a middle
ground on this there's a lot of a lot of
people that believe in these things that
are totally separate from the role of
climate change and a lot of these
recycling and energy efficiency policies
are very good and I think most people
would agree with them and most of people
are trying to
here to them I think what we're talking
about again is the imposition whether
you force people to have drought
resistant lawns or you force people to
have solar panels on their roof I don't
see any reason why people can't make
choices like that on their own when it
comes down to it like those choices we
make what we buy what whatever we vote
on is is it doesn't have to be expensive
but what we're trying to do is prevent
these costs from getting bigger
long term I mean I think we just simply
need to change some of our choices and
be a little altruistic I worry about our
future yes I definitely worried about
our future it's something I think about
a lot because I watch and because I work
with the data from climate science all
over the country and all over the world
and I especially worried because I have
three young sons one of whom just has
his birthday today and I'm very worried
that the planet they're gonna inherit is
already going to be much much more
difficult to live on than the one I
inherited when my parents gave to me the
Constitution preamble last part of it
says to secure the blessings of liberty
to ourselves and our posterity I'm
concerned about them having Liberty
having the freedom some people think
that we don't have the right to choose
you know how we should live I mean
because you want to force your way of
life on others I have four grandsons
that I love more than life I fear for
their future that they that they are
going to be living in a socialist
country because this is what this leads
to I don't have a voice in this state at
all I have no voice I worry about the
future because I have four nieces and
nephew and I'd like to have a family in
my own someday and have kids and so I
think about the future and how degraded
the environment could be or how the
amount of co2 we're putting into the air
and greenhouse gases increases but I'm
hopeful because I found that there are
people living in way worse conditions
that I am and they're full of hope
because they understand
and that they have choices that they can
work hard to make a better life for
themselves I don't know about you guys
but at least for me I'm gonna make
choices that improve the environment
improve public health and leave this
place better for for the future
generations I'm just I'm not I'm not in
fear I have made the choice to not have
children and I honor that decision and
we all have that choice and I don't
operate from a place of fear a big
question that I don't know if we've
addressed today or if we ever will
address is who takes responsibility for
the impact that we're having because we
know that we have an impact so I just
believe in using our purchasing power
our political power through our vote
through supporting policies that are
going to create healthier communities
and basically doing the best that we can
so that we can continue to enjoy our
environment now and for future
generations everybody thank you for
watching another episode of middle
ground my name is Erin and this is Dan
and we are both Jubilee directors I
think um you know we obviously have our
own beliefs that we carry through our
own lives and then when you are
directing an episode of middle-ground
what's interesting is when you start
reaching out to cast members to be in
the episode you start talking from
people who you actually disagree with I
wouldn't say it makes you agree with
them always but you do empathize and
listen a lot more you can't just dismiss
it completely you have to see the human
being coming with that opinion well if
you guys have any thoughts on what
you've learned for middle ground please
comment below be sure to follow us on
Instagram that's we're gonna find out a
lot more of what's coming up next in our
videos as well as behind the scenes
stuff with us
we'd love to get to know you there so
see that